welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast
we are back for season four and today's
episode begins with an exciting
announcement about what we've been so
busy
working on after that we discussed
plenty of new research
about plant-based proteins how fat-free
mass impacts mortality risk
and how your myers-briggs personality
type dictates the right form
of intermittent fasting for you one of
those topics
is less serious than the others so the
challenge is to uh
to try to pick out that one we've got
some practical training tips from a
coach's corner segment we've got a q a
segment that covers a lot of different
topics
including mouth guards for lifting sugar
sweetened beverages
atp and phosphatidic acid
supplementation
stretching flexibility adjusting your
training based on your calorie intake
and more finally to close out the show
great's got some great cooking resources
to bring to everyone's attention
as always thank you for listening and we
hope you enjoy the show
back to the stronger by science podcast
this is your
one and only full-time professional host
eric trexler
but today as we kick off season four i'm
joined by a special temporary guest
co-host
his name's greg knuckles greg how are
you doing
i'm doing well how are you i'm doing
well uh it's been a while
we we had a fireside chat well not we
you had a fireside chat episode
a while back but we've we've been kind
of
off the grid for a while so i feel like
some degree of explanation
is in order uh we have been
busy of course we've been doing a lot of
writing and stuff like that
but we've also been putting together a
diet app
uh which is pretty exciting so uh
here's my we're not gonna get into too
many details because it's you know it's
still
a ways off uh before we put it out there
but the way i view it so greg you're a
numbers boy
you like numbers you like analytics
i i refer to myself as a numbers man but
uh okay feel free to continue fair
enough
well i'm lazy uh you might have picked
up from some of my recipes
over the years i'm not really that into
putting a lot of effort into my cooking
and my tracking and actually you know
to be honest the reason that the reason
i eat the way i eat
is because i'm too lazy like i developed
my
my eating habits of having like three
ingredients per meal
that was because i used to track
everything i ate and i was like who
could possibly have the time to have six
items in a meal
you know six ingredients that's insane
cut that in half and we're talking
uh so the goal with this app in my from
my perspective
is to satisfy your love for numbers and
data and analytics
while also appeasing people as
disgustingly lazy as me and i i feel
like
as we continue working with it we're
getting close there
no i agree uh definitely
hard plus one for the laziness um
i probably historically should have
tracked my nutrition far
more than i did uh but yeah it was the
same sort of thing like
the the process of tracking was very
cumbersome
um i previously used myfitnesspal
and i uh like
on one hand it's cool that they had a
big database of stuff
and on the other hand it sucked that the
database was like
90 incorrect entries and so
you know you'd have to like sift through
four or five entries before you're just
like yeah those
those macros actually seem like the
right ones um
so yeah i uh i have previously tracked
quite a bit
and have never been able to stick with
it for very long because
either i would start drifting towards
what you're describing where you know
you just eat like four foods
you know what entries you use um and
that's not sustainable for me
because i do like to get a little bit
more adventurous in the kitchen
uh or you know i'd just be like super
annoyed and pissed off taking like
[ __ ] 20 minutes to track every meal
um
so yeah the the app that we're working
on with uh
and by we're working on i mean we kind
of
supplied the the raw materials in terms
of like
information and approach for adjusting
things
uh and our developers corey and rebecca
have
been doing the vast majority of the
actual work
uh obviously but uh man the
the pre-alpha build already is
so sick like even if i didn't have
financial stake in this
um i i think i would still view it as
like
head and shoulders above what i've used
previously
yeah and that's a good clarification
like uh
i think it's a pretty slick macro
tracker
like as it stands like a good food
logging app but
we laid the foundation for how it
actually makes adjustments so it doesn't
it's not just a food tracker it also you
know you can put in your goal for for
managing your weight
and it'll kind of coat you through the
process in terms of dictating your your
macro targets so
there's a lot of ins and outs and we're
pretty stoked about it but that's that's
what we've been busy with
and uh you'll hear about it more in the
future as it comes a little bit closer
to market in the meantime
if you really want to support us
everybody knows how to do it you go to
bulksupplements.com you put in the promo
code sbs pod
that's one of the things i'm most proud
of in my career is seeing
how how much generational wealth we've
helped our listeners develop
uh from that five percent discount that
you get
it's been crazy to see everybody
flourishing
and and making so much money and
investing it back into their communities
uh it's been really rewarding so keep
using that promo code and keep
reaping those enormous benefits um
you know that that honestly sounds like
a good news segment in and of itself but
we do have a good news segment as well
and i'm going to start off with that i'm
going to keep it short and sweet
vaccine numbers are looking good in the
united states
hasn't necessarily been a perfect roll
out but
uh you know it's it's been very
impressive i've been really stoked to
see that
and given that kovid's been on the top
of mind for about
you know 13 14 months at this point
uh it's short it's simple but damn
that's some good news to see people
getting vaccines it's really cool
absolutely so
so my good news uh which i'm presenting
without
a shred of sarcasm or irony is uh
so i mean there there was a
relatively recent election in the us uh
the trump administration went out the
biden administration came in
and long-time listeners of the podcast
will know uh
we actually had a pretty close advisory
relationship with the trump
administration
uh their their fda was basically at our
beck and call
any time that we asked for a
clarification for something
specifically related maybe to the
legality of cbd supplements
you know they'd come out with a
clarification like within a week so
you know we we were concerned that our
access
to the halls of power might be
threatened
uh by the incoming administration
however
um that is not the case so
when uh when the biden administration
came in
i i sent him a letter um said like
hey look mr joe uh
we underst we understand that uh the
previous administration
did allow some uh some weed heads
some people who took to the reefer to
work in the white house which
uh quite honestly terrible idea i i
can't understand why any
why anyone would allow that so he said
hey
maybe uh you know if if there's one
big line item that can really uh clean
up federal policy like if there's one
thing you could do to improve american
society
it would definitely be to get all of the
pod heads out of the white house
uh and the biden administration 100
obliged um the actual news story
honestly i find pretty hilarious the uh
the uh administration asked people
coming in to just like fill out a form
and like one of the questions is
have you ever like recreationally used
marijuana
and the people who said yes like within
months they basically said like yeah get
the [ __ ] out of here we don't want you
and honestly uh so now
obviously the last part was sarcasm uh
but this isn't sarcasm
honestly i do kind of think that that's
that's kind of a good thing because like
anyone who's [ __ ] stupid enough to
tell the truth to the federal government
about using drugs that are still illegal
in the federal level
i don't want them in the government it's
like questionable judgment yeah i i
don't care if someone smokes weed but if
someone is going to tell the federal
government that they smoke weed
i i don't want them anywhere close to
the to the levers of power that
that shows zero common sense that they
would tell the truth about that
um so anyway that that's my uh
that's my joke good news story i will
say um
[Laughter]
it's you know when we started this
podcast we mentioned that
we wanted to follow in the footsteps of
rush limbaugh
rest in peace and he he used to always
remind people you know these politicians
come and go
they serve their term they hit the road
but i'm always here
and it's nice that we've kind of
replicated that you know when we would
ask the trump administration for some
clarification we get it
and now it looks like uh the biden
administration is also kind of
understanding the power dynamic there
which is good yeah yeah for sure
um but no so so my actual good news
story and this
is not not a pure and unfiltered good
news story but
from me i don't think anyone expects
that anymore uh there's
there's a tinge of shot and freudia here
um
but there was another uh retraction that
came through
with the uh the the barbago
investigation that
that i was a part of we haven't talked
about this a ton on the podcast
yet because i i feel like this isn't a
story i want to drag out across
you know half a dozen episodes anytime
that there's new
information that comes in i think that
this would be a good thing to cover
fully in depth uh once everything is
fully concluded
but basically uh last year
myself and several other people
including andrew vigotsky james steele
brad schoenfeld james heathers
uh james fisher we uh krieger
yeah yeah james krieger too many james's
far too many james's
uh we we all kind of like independently
noticed
that there was a fair amount of data
that looked
uh somewhat atypical coming out of
one particular lab group in rapid
succession
we we dug into it we found some things
that said
that that were very statistically
anomalous uh i'll just
i'll just leave it at that um patterns
in the data that were very improbable
correct correct um if you want the the
full story on that as it stands
currently
you can go to strongerbyscience.com
barbalio that'll be linked in the show
notes uh if you want to read about
you know what what we found when poking
around in that data
but the good news is uh well the bad
news is that
a lot of those studies that had uh what
what were in my opinion
very strange looking things
most of the journals haven't retracted
the studies and haven't even published
expressions of concern
but we did recently get another
retraction from
medicine and science and sport and
exercise and it was
to give bruce gladden and the editorial
team at msse
credit they published a really really
strong
retraction statement one of my general
complaints with
retractions often is that the journals
often try to use retractions to save
face they
they'll basically just use like the most
wishy-washy language
imaginable not really give any details
um to not make it look like oh man we
accidentally let something
bad slip through so the the mssc
retraction statement
i'll just read it it's it's pretty short
um but it's
this is how i think retraction
statements should read
uh so so all the credit in the world to
to dr gladden and his team
so it says the editor-in-chief of
medicine and science in sport and
exercise is retracting this article
because of concerns about the veracity
of the data
two authors of the article raised
questions regarding the data in the
article and requested that it be
retracted those two authors were james
fisher and james steele
the other authors and their institutions
were contacted and permitted to respond
those authors and institutions reported
no irregularities in the conduct of the
research
however at the request of the
editor-in-chief of medicine and science
and sport and exercise
four content area experts with
statistical expertise
investigated the data in detail
considered the author and institutional
responses
and provided evaluations based on their
report and all pertinent information
gathered
the data were judged to be highly
unusual correspondingly dubious
and insufficiently trustworthy medicine
and science and sport and exercise is a
member of
the committee on publication ethics or
cope and is committed to the very
highest standards in publication ethics
msse has followed the processes set
forth by cope for handling of such
matters
um so yeah laid out
the investigation that took place the
reasons for the retraction
very very good retraction statement for
people just kind of like keeping score
and
people who followed uh chatter in the
fitness industry
a couple years ago the
there were two volume studies that came
out of that lab
around this time so comparing training
with 5
10 15 and 20 sets per week generally
finding
greater hypertrophy and strength
outcomes with lower training volume so 5
or 10 sets per week
than higher training volumes so pretty
large drop-offs
from 10 to 15 sets per week and 15 to 20
sets per week
and those findings were pretty anomalous
um you know most most research does tend
to find more hypertrophy with moderate
to higher volumes
both of those studies have now been
retracted one of the other
so the the the two studies were
basically mirror images of each other
one
in males one in females the mail volume
study was retracted last year now the
female volume study has been retracted
so both of those are off the books now
which
in my opinion helps unmuddy the water in
that general area of research quite a
bit so that that's a kind of fringe
benefit here
um makes makes the whole like volume and
hypertrophy body of literature
uh a little bit less confusing a little
bit easier to parse
uh so anyway in my opinion uh big win
for publication ethics
i feel to some degree kind of personally
vindicated
uh because the whole investigation
did take a lot of time and a lot of
effort
so get another retraction coming out of
it
for me personally is is gratifying on a
personal level
um and yeah msse is the most
prestigious journal that any of the
papers from that lab group were
published in so
the the msse retraction is is pretty big
on that front as well
and hopefully on the back of that some
of the other journals will
reevaluate some of the decisions they've
made up to this point
yeah and whenever this topic comes up i
think it's always helpful to clarify a
couple
big things it's it's very common uh
for people to kind of misinterpret the
these conversations a bit and
you know this type of thing isn't some
kind of vendetta that you guys have it's
not settling a score it's not
promoting uh you know some kind of
uh approach to training that you all
share it's just about making sure that
the literature
we're making inferences about uh is is
rock solid
making sure that all the the data that
make up the literature
are are really robust and reliable that
we can make inferences from
so so uh you know having um
having clarifications and corrections
and retractions is part of the process
of making sure that we're interpreting
literature
uh that we can have really uh strong
conclusions from you know really robust
data
and the other important thing about your
investigation i think you guys
did a remarkably good job uh really
hammering this point home in all of your
the white paper
the article on the stronger by science
site is that
it's not an accusation and it's not
about why or how
you know what i mean so a lot of people
hear this they start making inferences
about
who did what and who's accusing who of
what and that really has nothing to do
with it you know you guys
i think made a really compelling case in
your work
that it doesn't matter why or how the
data
came to be this way but they have
patterns that are highly improbable
and therefore we have to be really
cautious about like what one in
10 billion one and a hundred billion yes
improbable
yeah yeah calculated extremely low
probability yeah not not like one in a
thousand because
there's thousands of studies that get
done like one in a thousand shit's gonna
happen all the time but like
one in several quadrillion that's
the sort of things you shouldn't
necessarily expect to see
often if ever exactly and i think you
guys did a great job keeping focused on
the the entire purpose of this thing was
to ensure
uh you know that we've got a really
robust body of literature to make
inferences about
and that it you know it's not an
accusation thing it's not about
uh you know vendettas or settling scores
i think you guys you guys did a great
job with that and just pointing out
straightforward
these are very improbable observations
and therefore
you know it's probably not safe to be
using these to
make inferences about how we program
training off this data
uh so props to you guys for doing such a
great job with that and props to
msse for you know for looking at it
objectively and saying okay
if the question is about probabilities
let's bring in people who
who really have a good understanding of
this statistical stuff and say
you know what do you think of the
veracity of this data how generalizable
is it how robust is it
should it stay in the literature or not
you know so props to everybody involved
there
and now we've got some feats of strength
uh yeah so we haven't done a normal
episode in like two or three months so
a lot of strong people have done a lot
of strong stuff so i'm
absolutely going to not talk about all
of them because then feats of strength
would be like
two and a half hours long uh but but so
some
uh recent strong person things in in the
last
month that that i thought were uh were
pretty cool
one is uh the the next time
uh raw nationals rolls around the squat
world record in the 83 kilo class
uh i'm locking this prediction in that
record will fall
i'm pretty sure it's 313 kilos and uh
there are two people just toying with
that amount of weight and training
so uh russell ori who currently has the
world record in that class
uh he squatted 310 or 683 for a set of
four
so around this time last year i think he
was setting a ton of squat pr's but like
the training reps were a little high but
uh a lot of folks myself included
were just like hey he's always been able
to get lifts in on the platform before
this probably isn't a big deal
um anyway when he did compete after that
just
insane looking training cycle he did
have issues with hitting depth on the
platform and so
uh this time around he's hitting similar
numbers but to
depth that looks pretty good so uh yeah
it's
it's looking like he's gonna put some
insane number on the platform
um but once again in the same weight
class i need to give
a shout out to jamar royster uh
raleigh guy uh great dude doesn't get
nearly as much recognition as he
deserves in that same weight class i
believe
he also looks like he's about to
absolutely
[ __ ] on the record um he recently
squatted
uh 733 for a double in training that's
uh 332 and a half kilos at 83
which is uh one 183 um
that's a lot of weight uh and i think
russell
and jamar's squats currently are very
neck and neck
uh and man i could see that world record
going north of uh
of 750 or 340 the next time both of them
get on the platform
so uh as a fan of the sport that will be
exciting to see
as as a raleigh homer
and as someone who knows jamar i hope
jamar's the one who comes out on top
but either way i think we're going to
see just an absolutely insane squat
number in that class soon
um let's get some equipped lifting
action
in the mix uh haven't talked about
equipped lifting in quite a while on
feats of strength
uh but jimmy cobb uh i assume that's how
you pronounce his name kolb
i think that's generally cobb either
cobb or colb
um he benched uh 490 kilos or a thousand
and eighty pounds
in single ply uh which broke his own
world record in the class uh and
that is that is wild to me uh like i
know equipment has gotten better over
time but i remember when i got into
lifting
uh gene uh richlock
and uh scott mendelsohn were still the
only two people who had ever benched a
thousand in multiply
and then ryan canelli came in and for my
money
the last really solid multiply world
record was probably canelli's 1075.
after that a lot of the lockouts started
looking kind of soft
kind of iffy uh whatever the
that world record is now in excess of
500 kilos but
uh the the 1075 was the last one that i
was really impressed with
jimmy uh 1080 in single ply
very solid um full lockout controlled it
well
um not soft elbows so very very
impressive bench there
um i mean just to support a thousand
pounds in your hands
i cannot fathom that uh and to bench it
in single ply
doubly impressive so very very cool
stuff there
uh i know i'm gonna butcher this name
but uh
tomas hotala i believe uh ipf lifter
pulled 420 kilos or 925 pounds in
training
uh i believe he competes in the 105 kilo
class or 231 and walks around
at like 108 109 give or take um
looked pretty looked solid looked like
there was a little bit more left in the
tank
uh if he were to put that number on the
platform
that would be i believe the heaviest
deadlift ever pulled on a stiff bar
period
um and and certainly the heaviest
deadlift ever pulled in the ipf
or uh in ipf affiliate the
current highest uh the current highest
in an ipf affiliate
was uh mikhail kikliav back when he
competed tested he pulled
uh 920 or uh yeah 920 pounds
or 417 and a half kilos it's super heavy
so
uh the fact that someone is is exceeding
that a weight class or two weight
classes down
uh truly wild stuff uh his
his deadlift is a thing of beauty and
you should check that out
um and then the the last one i want to
end on
is uh hunter henderson very very strong
very impressive
uh untested female lifter squatted
6 15 in training uh
very smooth her form is immaculate
like one of the most efficient squats
i've ever seen
um you can count the number of
women who have uh squatted that much
and this is raw with raps by the way uh
you can count the number of women who've
done that on one hand
um and she's
she's a middleweight so i mean like uh
i i have no idea where her squad is
going in the coming years but that
at 6 15 she hit looked very easy and
very solid
um oh actually i said that was the last
one
there there's one more that i'm going to
mention uh just because like
20 people on instagram sent this to me
and said like oh you got to talk about
this on feeds of strength
um joe kovacs a uh
shot put thrower from the good ol us and
a
uh so not a power lifter not a weight
lifter
someone for whom the squat is an
accessory lift
to get better at throwing
a large metal ball he squatted
870 for a set of four
so one thing to note two things to note
one it was filmed in the buckeyes weight
room
so i feel like that's
i feel like we do have to apply a
correction i i assume most people can
probably squat an extra 100 150 pounds
just through walking
just by walking through those doors uh
also
the lift the lift itself was filmed at
the worst possible angle to
see basically anything about the squat
um
it was filmed from dead in front and
very
highly elevated above the lifter
i think i think he probably squatted
like fairly high
um but again it's it's impossible to
tell for sure from the angle but also
like
who [ __ ] cares he's he's a shotput
thrower uh
there is no required squat depth uh when
you are throwing shot put at a highly
competitive level
uh that is not what they contest but
regardless i mean
it was it was like i would say a good
faith effort at decent depth uh
and so seeing that type of weight move
for four reps
for someone where squatting isn't their
sport
uh absolutely insane uh elite throwers
are so strong and also so explosive
um it it doesn't make sense
uh if you want to see just some
some very very large people
do insanely athletic stuff uh
you should check out uh shot put in
discus throwers they're
just just freak athletic specimens
uh and and this is this is one of the
more impressive lifts i've i've seen
from a thrower
all right moving on with the show uh i
know we each have some research
that we want to talk about i'll go ahead
and start um
i basically need to begin with a big
apology
uh to the game changers universe and
everybody associated with it
james cameron everybody uh so
there's that old phrase eating crow you
know when you're kind of admitting you
were wrong and
i'm eating a plant-based maybe soy
crow substitute here um
one of the things i've been really
looking into lately
i'm being sarcastic by the way i would
never apologize for anything earnestly
so i've been looking into plant-based
proteins and
it's basically been through mass there
have been a couple studies the last few
months
that have looked at muscle protein
synthesis over a few days
with a vegan diet versus an omnivorous
diet
and then another study looking at actual
hypertrophy over
several weeks with a vegan diet versus
an omnivorous diet
and you know i feel like ever since i
got into
the whole evidence-based fitness thing
it's been
essentially unanimous everybody agrees
if you're looking at a plant-based
protein versus an animal-based protein
the animal-based one is going to be
superior when it comes to stimulating
muscle protein synthesis but there is
some new stuff coming out
in the the plant-based protein research
that i think is really fascinating
and requires kind of an update of our uh
the way we discuss plant-based proteins
here so the game changers documentary
we've talked about it in the past on the
show
uh far more than it deserved it made a
bunch of
kind of uh exaggerated claims in my
opinion
about exactly what the benefits of a
plant-based diet or a vegan diet might
be
but that doesn't mean that that we
should uh
discredit those diets altogether you
know they still have plenty of
very positive attributes there's still
plenty of great reasons
to adopt a more plant-based or a vegan
diet and they absolutely are a
viable dietary strategy and there's no
question about that
the question is if you switch from an
omnivorous diet to
a vegan diet or a heavily plant-based
diet
what type of sacrifices might you be
making in the process you know what are
the pros and cons
and what types of accommodations do you
have to make
in response to removing some key food
groups from your diet you know removing
uh you know depending on what kind of
diet you go on you might be removing
dairy eggs poultry meat and and so on so
the question is what are you giving up
when you switch over to a vegan diet and
is it actually less favorable when it
comes to
supporting gains and muscle mass
supporting muscle protein synthesis and
things of that nature
and a couple studies have come along the
last few months that have really
kind of provided a lot more insight a
more nuanced understanding
of how we can compare plant-based and
animal-based proteins so
ever since i got into this whole
evidence-based
nutrition world especially when it comes
to the lifting
side of that world it's been pretty much
agreed upon
that animal protein sources are better
than plant-based protein sources
and there's there's really been a few
key areas where
that conclusion is drawn from so first
there's just very straightforward
uh scores for different proteins there
are
a lot of different ways that you can
assess
quantitatively a protein's quality score
it usually comes down to its amino acid
profile
is it lacking any key essential amino
acids if so what is the rate limiting
essential amino acid
how digestible is the protein it comes
down to simple things like that
and so generally speaking animal protein
sources are going to be
higher quality in these scoring systems
than a plant-based protein source
another area where we draw this
conclusion is based on
extremely acute interventions so looking
at studies where they observe
uh you know muscle protein synthesis
after a
single dose or a single serving of a
plant protein or an animal protein and
when you look at these protein scores
when you look at these
very acute study designs looking at a
few hours of muscle protein synthesis
uh it's very clear why people lean
toward favoring animal-based proteins
they definitely have higher protein
scores quality scores
and they definitely in an acute setting
induce larger muscle protein synthesis
responses but it's always important to
recognize in these types of scenarios
that
those aren't the true outcomes we're
interested in you know we're generally
interested in seeing
if i'm on an omnivorous diet or a vegan
diet
does one impact my ability to make gains
more than the other is one going to more
effectively support my ability to get
stronger
and build muscle and so there have been
uh
some studies over the last few months
that have looked at this plant versus
animal protein question from a variety
of different perspectives
so first of all if you want to get
caught up to speed on the muscle protein
synthesis stuff
very acutely there's a fantastic review
paper
by van vliet and colleagues and i'll
link that in the show notes
uh off air greg and i had a serious
discussion about how to pronounce that
last name
i'm deferring to him might be vanvlie
might be vanvleet uh
perhaps we'll never know but if we if we
find out uh
who am i kidding we're not going to
update that on the show but uh anyway i
think that would be a fun correction
to to add in yeah so maybe we will but
certainly no disrespect to the author
it's a really great uh
review paper that we'll link um now
there's another
there there's actually a meta-analysis
not a review paper but a full-blown
meta-analysis here
a systematic review with meta-analytic
techniques applied
that kind of got away from the
you know acute single dose muscle
protein synthesis stuff
and actually looked at longitudinal
changes in strength and body composition
but this time looking at supplement
interventions so instead of looking at
the acute response to a single dose it
was like okay
if we give one group soy protein and the
other group whey protein and they're
lifting and we observe over several
weeks
who's making better gains here so so it
was a very different
approach but again it's important to
recognize that we're still
in the context of people's typical diet
here so this
isn't vegan diet versus omnivorous diet
this is
with whatever you already eat we're
either going to give you a scoop of soy
protein each day or
a scoop of whey protein or something
like that plant source versus animal
source
and this meta-analysis another one i'll
link in the show notes is by lim
and colleagues and it was actually
interesting because
while the acute muscle protein synthesis
stuff is
very decidedly in favor of animal-based
proteins
that gap isn't quite as big within this
context when we look at longitudinal
changes
in the context of you know a normal diet
where we're
just supplementing one protein powder
versus the other
and so when looking at the results of
this meta-analysis you could probably
work your way toward concluding that
there was a slight advantage
for the animal-based proteins over the
plant-based proteins but you got to do a
little bit of work to get there
there was a decent amount of
heterogeneity with some of these
subgroups in these forest plots and
even you know what they found was if you
look at for example
lean mass in raw units versus
relative units you know there were some
different results there where
animal based proteins were better in one
case and no different in the other but
then
when they did their sensitivity analysis
and and they tried to assess how robust
those findings were
in both cases they flipped so i mean
from a statistical perspective
you could make a defensible but not
necessarily rock solid case that there
was a slight benefit favoring the
animal-based proteins here but
in practical terms you know just to put
some actual units to this
if you look at how much additional lean
mass was gained in this meta-analysis
with the animal-based protein
supplements versus the plant-based
we're talking about 0.2 kilograms you
know we're talking about a
very arguably negligible
amount of additional lean mass accretion
so uh
not a particularly strong finding
indicating that animal
animal-based protein supplement
interventions are far
superior to plant-based supplement
interventions but again
we're talking about one single serving
of protein here
versus actually switching over to a
totally vegan diet two very very
different things
so in the last couple months there have
been a couple papers that have come out
that are getting a little bit closer to
what we're really interested in so
uh with this particular question so
there's a paper by montene
and colleagues that i'll link in the
show notes here and
they were looking at two different high
protein diets so one was
a high protein vegan diet that was
heavily supplemented
with mycoprotein which is like a a
fungus derived protein source that has a
pretty good
amino acid profile and then it was being
compared to just a high protein
omnivorous diet so in both
cases they were having i believe it was
yeah it was 1.8 grams per kilogram of
protein per day which is plenty
and throughout there's a three-day
intervention throughout the intervention
they were doing
uh some resistance exercise
you know along with these high protein
interventions
and they were looking at muscle protein
synthesis but instead of looking at
you know their response to a single dose
or a single meal they were looking at it
over the three day period and in this
case
the mycoprotein supplemented
vegan diet supported muscle protein
synthesis over the study period
quite similarly when compared to the
omnivorous diet which was really
interesting but again
this is you know three days is better
than looking at a single meal response
in terms of what we're trying to make
inferences about but
it's still not truly a longitudinal
hypertrophy study
but fortunately very recently within the
last couple months there was
a really nice study that came out by
javia lorraine
and what they did was they looked at
again high protein diets
vegan versus omnivorous and both diet
groups
were having 1.6 grams per kilogram
per day of protein it was a 12-week
training intervention
where they were trained doing resistance
training twice per week
and like i said over these 12 weeks what
they're trying to see is
is the omnivorous diet actually leading
to
more hypertrophy or better strength
gains than a vegan diet and in this case
the vegan diet was heavily supplemented
again
but it was supplemented with soy protein
instead of mycoprotein and soy protein
again
has a pretty favorable amino acid
profile and
good digestibility as well so among
plant-based protein sources it's a
pretty high quality protein source
a really a really impressive strength of
this study
uh first of all they were looking at
younger people uh which
you don't see that some sometimes these
uh dietary interventions they focus on
uh populations that are susceptible to
sarcopenia and
and it's nice to every now and then you
know mix in some studies where they're
looking at younger folks who might be
uh might be a little bit more similar to
our
our listenership or our readership it's
stronger by science
so we're talking about people in their
20s here healthy folks
and uh yeah so over this 12-week
intervention
they're lifting weights and this was
nice because it gave a lot of different
perspectives so
it measured a performance outcome being
leg press one rep max but it also
looked at a whole body or i'm not whole
body but
whole leg lean mass via dexa it looked
at
hypertrophy at the whole muscle level
via ultrasound
and it also looked at hypertrophy at the
fiber level
so it was kind of looking at every layer
of hypertrophy whether you're looking at
the leg the muscle or the fiber itself
and what was really fascinating here was
just like the previous study looking at
protein synthesis over multiple days
this particular study seemed to indicate
that the the vegan diet and the
omnivorous diet led to
relatively similar gains when we're
talking about the strength outcomes and
the hypertrophy outcomes
and so uh i i think it's really
it's really important to recognize here
that they did everything right
uh in terms of trying to make sure that
the vegan diet uh
effectively supported hypertrophy so in
the past we've talked a little bit about
protein distribution
and in this case the vegan and the and
the omnivorous groups
they all had four protein servings per
day
kind of spread out through the day each
serving was
over was around or over 0.3 grams per
kilogram of protein
each serving provided plenty of
essential amino acids each serving
provided plenty of leucine two to three
grams of leucine per serving so
they were taking this vegan diet they
were using a high protein source being
soy
protein and they were spreading these
protein boluses throughout the day
uh in a way that is really consistent
with our current understanding
of protein distribution so uh you know
the important thing to keep in mind when
we look
at the two most recent studies here
showing that vegan diets have
similar effects on hypertrophy we have
to keep in mind that they were high
protein interventions
and we have to keep in mind that they
were using uh
protein supplements that were that had a
pretty good digestibility and pretty
good amino acid profiles so
we have to interpret these findings
within that context but
i think it's really important to
highlight these studies because they
indicate that
the the pretty large gap we see when we
compare proteins based on their
protein quality score or their acute
effect on muscle protein synthesis
that large gap seems to really really
shrink
based on the evidence that's coming out
recently when we look at the stuff we
actually care about which is
if i'm consuming this diet versus that
diet and i'm lifting hard
over time is one going to actually
support my lifting goals better than the
other
so we on the show we've always talked
about vegan diets as being a very viable
approach but we've talked about okay
what kind of accommodations do you have
to make you know there are some
micronutrients that
on a fully vegan diet the
bioavailability is lower or
because of the food sources that are
eliminated they're harder to get into
the diet there are some accommodations
that ought to be made when it comes to
putting together a really solid vegan
diet or heavily plant-based diet
one of the accommodations we've always
talked about is like well you know
you're giving up some value on your
protein sources
so you might need to increase your total
protein intake
or do a variety of different protein
related strategies to overcome that
these studies in my opinion are at at
the very least
indicating if your total protein intake
is high enough 1.6
1.8 2 grams per kilograms per day uh
and you know you're lifting throughout
the intervention and
your vegan diet contains protein sources
that are
pretty high quality things like soy
things like mico protein you don't have
any major
essential amino acid gaps you're
distributing your protein relatively
sensibly throughout the day
within those constraints i think these
studies give us a much more favorable
view
of the potential for plant-based or
vegan diets
to really effectively support
hypertrophy now
if you wanted to be extra cautious you
don't
lose anything by applying some of the
accommodations we've mentioned in the
past so
if you basically say well i might be
lacking this amino acid or that amino
acid
i might be sacrificing a little bit here
in protein quality
maybe i'm going to bump my protein when
i switch from omnivorous to vegan maybe
i'm going to bump it from 1.8 to 2 grams
per kilogram per day
if you want to make that adjustment
you're probably not
losing anything in the process it might
be viewed as kind of an
extra cautious approach but
i think it's important to highlight that
these studies show some pretty favorable
outcomes
with these plant-based diets as long as
you've got some decent protein sources
and you're distributing that protein
pretty effectively
and you've got plenty of protein there
there are some protein
uh interventions in the past that
indicated that
these animal-based diet omnivorous diets
i should say do a little bit better than
ovo lacto-vegetarian diets
when total protein intake is pretty low
and not matched between groups but
that's not super surprising
when you consider the juice the
discrepancies between
a slightly higher protein intake more
protein coming from higher quality
sources
within those constraints uh you know
there might be a bigger gap
but when you've got enough total protein
and some solid protein sources
i think these are um these are some
really encouraging findings for
for uh supporting plant-based proteins
uh
again some of the other claims in game
changers
you know still need some support
uh not sure if we're ever going to get
the study we need on those nocturnal
emissions but uh
emissions
you just cut out meat and just all night
long you're just shooting fat
ropes nocturnal erections there we go
yeah yeah um
haven't seen that study yet maybe
they'll fund it but uh
but yeah it's it's i think an important
update on plant-based protein uh because
it's looking a little bit more favorable
in some of these more
uh more relevant applications now yeah
that that
makes sense to me i i think uh j just on
a related note the next time
a really big uh
a really big just nutrition documentary
of any kind that royals the fitness
industry comes out
we should have a movie night uh because
i i feel like we could
we could really farm that for content i
think people respond pretty well
to to our game changers content um
and i i just feel like we could put
together a lot of
superior bits if both of us were in on
the joke
uh i still haven't seen game changers
never [ __ ] will
uh i will i will not watch that movie
alone
but i i i do think uh i i do think we
can make a fun movie night out of
uh out of the next big nutrition
documentary well first of all you
shouldn't watch
the documentary you should watch the 18
18-hour youtube
dice section of it um
because i mean you really the two-hour
movie is just the highlights
at that point i had forgotten about you
gotta dig deeper
uh but you know what we should do is do
some type of uh
like a live stream where we can watch it
with people
that would be cool that would be a lot
of fun we'll have to look into
how our dumb asses can try to make that
technology work i i think i could figure
it out
that's like everybody's like streaming
stuff these days it can't be that hard
to figure that out
a lot of people i know of who are a lot
dumber than us have twitch channels
that's that's what i was kind of getting
at without without saying it but yeah
pretty much i i am on this podcast to
say the quiet part out loud
yeah are we ready to move on yeah yeah i
think you've got a little bit of
research to cover as well
yeah i i do um so
i want to talk about a recent study
by settlemeyer and colleagues uh the
title of which is
relation of body fat mass and fat-free
mass to total mortality
colon results from seven prospective
cohort studies
that will be linked in the show notes um
and so i wanted to talk about this
because i think it does a pretty good
job
of clearing up a a pretty common
argument
that i see in in the fitness industry in
a lot of comments sections etc
anytime that bmi is brought up
so um if someone
mentions bmi that's kind of like uh
it's like a siren song that is going to
attract probably 40 percent of power
lifters and bodybuilders
on the planet into the comments section
to say like bmi's dumb
uh it can't tell the difference between
fat and fat and muscle
uh like the why anyone puts
any weight at all on this metric is
beyond me
modern medicine is stupid bmi is stupid
etc etc
and then to that you'll often see the
common
counter claim of uh
well no actually uh
bmi doesn't distinguish between fat and
muscle but it is in fact
actually still bad to be at a
uh relatively high bmi even if a lot of
that
is coming from muscle um like it
that's still bad for you and often the
purported mechanism people throw out
there
is that just if your body is larger
period
that's going to put more strain on your
heart just because you need to perfuse
more total tissue and that's going to
make your heart work harder
which i guess theoretically might make
it give out
sooner uh but but anyway that's that's
the common
uh counter claim i see that that uh
logic is dangerously getting close to
the old donald trump theory of just
conserving your heartbeats well yeah i
mean that's obviously one
uh one fatal flaw in that idea uh the
other thing is if we want to be
a little bit more uh a little bit more
rigorous about it
um so uh it is true that if you have
just more body mass period you do need
blood vessels to feed
that body mass but ultimately in
major disclaimer don't take anything i'm
about to say as medical advice
talk to your doctor etc um but but
ultimately
the thing that's going to affect load on
your heart strain on your heart
is the blood pressure that you have and
the resistance
that your heart is dealing with and
trying to pump blood out against
uh and so here's here's some nerd [ __ ]
for you i'm gonna
badly mispronounce this but if
if we're going to talk about how hard
the heart has to work we need to talk
about the resistance that it's
encountering
and you can calculate that using the
haagen-puecel
equation uh
french people don't tell me i pronounced
that wrong because i know i did
uh but anyway that that equation is what
you would use to like
calculate resistance in any sort of
vessel where you're
pushing fluid through be that blood
vessels be that pipes whatever
and so that equation is uh eight times
the length of the vessel
times the viscosity of whatever liquid
you're dealing with
divided by pi times the radius of
the vessel squared and so it's it's
directly proportional to the length of
the vessel so basically if you have more
total length of blood vessels that is
going to increase the resistance your
heart is dealing with
but it's inversely proportional to
the radius of the vessel raised to the
fourth power so that's going to have
the radius of the vessel has a way
outsized
effect on resistance compared to length
so
you know it's it scales with length to
the first power
and radius to the fourth power so
something scaled to the fourth power
that's
that's going to have a much much larger
effect and just to quantify this a
little bit i wanted to
see basically like how
uh how how long the total blood vessels
in your body were
uh and then compare that to
[Music]
how many additional miles of blood
vessels are
added by gaining fat
and or muscle or whatever just just
additional tissue
uh turns out that was harder than i
thought it would be like
that's not just like a handy thing that
you can search on pubmed so
i googled it and a lot of sources were
saying like
about a hundred thousand miles of blood
vessels in the human body so that that's
for adults so that seems uh fairly
plausible like i've seen that claim
enough
hopefully it's not complete [ __ ]
because everyone's out there repeating
it
but then when i searched how many
additional uh
miles of blood vessels you add
per pound of fat and or muscle i saw
numbers
ranging anywhere from 5 miles to 200
miles
which uh that's a pr that's a pretty big
range
uh but but it's worth noting
it actually doesn't matter all that much
for our purposes here
so let's take the high number there
let's say it's 200 additional miles of
blood vessels
per pound of muscle that you gain
and let's say that you're you're talking
about the the difference of being
you know say a bmi of 23
with you know some amount of muscle
versus a bmi pushing 30 with 20 more
pounds of muscle
so that's that's a large difference in
muscle mass
and those 20 additional pounds of muscle
times 200
that would be an additional 4 000 miles
of blood vessels
based on the highest estimate i came
across in my google search that seems
like kind of a
high a high-end type estimate so
if you already have about a hundred
thousand miles adding
an additional four thousand miles you're
increasing
length by four percent uh which
would increase resistance by four
percent which
still pales in comparison to effects on
vessel radius which you know would be
affected by things like
atherosclerosis and just like artery
disease in general so basically
even with like a high end scenario when
we're talking about a difference in
muscle mass of like 20 pounds
you're not looking at a particularly
large difference in resistance caused by
those additional blood vessels uh
so ultimately i don't think that that's
that big of a diff
or that big of a thing like that that
mechanistic claim
you have more muscle make your heart
work harder i i don't think that there's
great reason to believe that that would
be the case
but anyway let's uh let's get back to
this study by settlemeyer
um that actually directly looks at the
topic at hand
so uh basically is
what they did is they found uh seven
prospective cohort studies that means
you you take a group of people
you measure things about them and then
you don't actually do an intervention
but you just
assess them over time and in this case
they were looking at basically like
over time did people die and
what effects or how
does bmi fat mass index
and fat free mass index how do those
things associate
with mortality risk in the cohorts in
these seven studies
so uh bmi is just fat mass index plus
fat free mass index they're all
you know total body mass or total fat
mass or total fat free mass divided by
height in meters squared
so just fmi plus ffmi equals bmi
and they basically wanted to decompose
bmi into fat mass index and fat-free
mass index
and look at varying levels of those two
metrics
and their associations with alcohol's
mortality
and so what they found uh and like i
said seven
seven uh prospective cohort studies
going into this
uh a total of a little bit over 16 000
total subjects uh what they found
is as far as fat mass index goes pretty
unsurprisingly
uh it's best for your fat mass index to
be pretty low
so uh anything below about seven
it seems is pretty good um
the the the hazard ratio is like
slightly tailing up
at really really low numbers so like i
don't know i
i feel like it's fairly intuitive that
just being like diced to the socks
all the time yeah probably not the best
thing you can do for your health
but for the most part as long as fat
mass index is reasonably low
uh uh all calls mortality is pretty low
and then once fat mass index gets above
about 10
or so there's a fairly linear
relationship between
fat mass index and all cause mortality
rates
so once fat mass index starts getting up
into the 15 to 20 range you're dealing
with
hazards ratios in the two to three range
that's
that's a pretty substantial elevation
and risk but then when we move over to
the fat free mass index
uh basically what we see is a
pretty linear negative relationship
between fat mass index and all-cause
mortality such that
or fat-free mass index so basically as
fat free mass index
increases all calls mortality decreases
to about a fat-free mass index in the
19-20 range
and then basically from a fat-free mass
index of 19
or 20 on up it's flat so if your
fat-free mass index is 20
you're probably pretty good if it's 22
you're probably pretty good
if it's 27 which is as high as the date
of wind in this study
you're probably pretty good so uh
variations in fat free mass index from
about 19 or 20 all the way up to about
27
not associated with changes in all call
in all calls mortality risk so basically
uh i i think that this unfortunately
uh does kind of support the
the bro case here that uh four lifters
bmi might be kind of dumb
um basically as long as you're pretty
lean
like and we're not talking like shredded
here like
the the the what what the levels of
uh fat mass index that are associated
with low relative risk here
were they would equate to body fat
percentages in
you know basically like 20 25
and below um and and they did include
both males and females
in here so probably a little bit lower
for males and probably a little bit
higher for females
but basically like as long as you're as
long as you're looking at
somewhat decent body comp uh
big big is fine bigger isn't necessarily
better
it's not necessarily worse and so like
on
a practical level if you have pretty
good genetics
for uh getting big
it's not completely inconceivable that
you could have a fat free mass index of
20
like 26 still be fairly lean so you have
a fat mass index of five
that would come out to a 16 body fat
and in that case your bmi would be 31
and this study
or this analysis based on seven
perspective cohort studies with a lot of
subjects going in
suggests that that would not be
associated with elevated mortality risk
um your your risk there would be about
the same as if your
fat free mass index was say 19 and your
fat mass index was still
five uh and your bmi was 24.
so um yeah this this i think
is a this was cool because like i i've
seen
that argument that i alluded to be had a
lot
by a lot of people i don't see people
actually dropping links to to show like
oh no
here's the independent associations
between fat-free mass index and bmi and
fat mass index and mortality it's
it's kind of just people making like
rationalist arguments like oh no
you get big hard work hard you die fast
like that's
uh that's kind of the level of discourse
but no unfortunately and this this irks
me a little bit because
uh the chorus of comments in every
comment section
by all of the lifters saying uh bmi's
dumb and doctors are stupid
it does annoy me like it just irks me to
see
all of those comments but like they're
kind of right they kind of have a point
um as long as you're pretty lean getting
big
uh doesn't seem like it's going to
negatively impact
uh alcohol's mortality risk again based
on this study
don't take this as medical advice all
standard disclaimers apply
i just think it's great that this study
included rampant
steroid abusers because as you noted the
the upper range of fat free mass index
was 27.
yeah uh and as we know as we know no
drug-free person has ever been that big
yeah i mean it'd be great if they did
but it's just not going to happen
yeah all right looks like you've also
got some cutting edge research to
discuss here
uh about intermittent fasting
and one's myers-briggs personality type
i i was gonna save that for uh
the reveal of the bit but that's fine uh
steal my thunder i don't care
uh so i i came across something
on facebook the other day that i thought
was absolutely hilarious
i think it was a screenshot someone
shared to the the macros inc facebook
group
uh but it's an ad from a company called
do fasting
uh it's a sponsored post and uh
basically they're they're taking you to
a page where you can take a quiz
to figure out what type of intermittent
fasting
is best for you uh and this is kind of
like
uh like okay cupid with like their 27
dimensions of compatibility they're
leaving no stone unturned
a a small brained diet coach
might think like oh someone's interested
in intermittent fasting what kind should
they do
they might ask stupid questions such as
well what fits your preferences best
do do you know maybe you want to do 16
8 intermittent fasting if you just want
to skip breakfast
uh maybe if you're uh trying to improve
metabolic flexibility you might go with
like
a 24 like a 20 hour fast four hour
feeding window to have like a longer
fasting period
uh if if you're a brad pilon devotee you
might
say like okay you're gonna eat normally
most days and then you're gonna have two
one or two 24 hour fast per week like if
that fits
your preference is best so that those
might be some approaches that a very
small brained diet coach would
would do you know uh mostly ask about
preferences but no this is far more
scientific than that
they ask about things such as what is
your blood type
what is your age because obviously
different intermittent fasting
approaches are
more or less appropriate for people of
different age ranges there's
tons of research on that that i'm sure
we're all very aware of
and then also what is your personality
type
with reference to the myers-briggs uh
personality inventory uh
before i get into that i also want to
note that on
on this graphic they lay out like four
different fasting options that that all
of this stuff
can filter you into um
so one of them's 14 14 10 which is 14
hour fast 10 hour feeding window
which is basically just like eat a late
breakfast and early dinner
and that adds up to 24. correct yeah
yeah that seems fine
another one is 12 12. that's not even
intermittent fasting in my book like a
12 hour feeding window is a normal ass
feeding window
breakfast at night in the morning and
dinner at night at night yeah that's
that's that's an unbelievably normal
feeding window for someone to have
if anything maybe it may be a tad long
yeah so congratulations
everyone is intermittent fasting uh the
the next is classic lean gain style 16
8 16 hour fast eight hour feeding window
or in other words basically just skip
breakfast
but then this last one on the list here
is 36-0
so one i did i did not realize days had
36 hours and two
nothing seems particularly intermittent
about that fast
you fast for six hours or or you fast
for 36 hours
you feed for zero hours it seems you
fast for another 36
i i don't see where the feeding window
goes in there
no that that's um i was going to point
that out i'm glad you covered that
because i'm like
there is no indic i i want more
reassurance that i will ever eat again
this 36-0
window does not sound fun yeah
yeah so um that was the ad
and i mostly just wanted to talk about
it uh just
just so our podcast listeners will
become aware
that myers-briggs is fake um
it like it is a thing that exists but
it's also
something that you shouldn't put any
stock in whatsoever
so to the degree to which it has
some degree of value um
it's because like the four axes of the
myers-briggs personality
inventory uh correlate with the first
four parts of the big four so it doesn't
uh
it doesn't account for the fifth part or
the big five i mean it doesn't account
for the fifth part of the big five which
is neuroticism
uh but some some of the parts uh
correlate with the big five the big five
is um
it has a lot more research backing it up
so if you're gonna choose one of the two
big five is objectively the better
choice to go with
uh and also like my myers-briggs i don't
think a lot of people are aware
the degree to which it's just like
completely made up
and pretty unvalidated and i think
people aren't aware just because it is
so common like it's used in a lot of
business settings it's used in a lot of
educational settings
the people who developed it weren't
psychologists they weren't
psychometricians
uh they were basically just a couple
people who came across
carl young one time and they were just
like damn dude like this guy has some
has some sick ideas uh let's just like
take it and kind of like dumb it down
a lot and sort people into personality
types
um like around
half of the published research
supporting the use
of the of the myers-briggs test is
published in a journal called the
journal of psychological type
which if you haven't heard of it uh
that's because it's
it's not a uh well-regarded
well-cited journal uh it is uh
associated with the myers-briggs test uh
i i think like
every editor of that journal ever has
been a proponent of
myers-briggs like it's it seems to be a
journal that exists
to launder the myers-briggs into the
published research
um and uh here's a fun
conflict of interest you can buy
myers-briggs personality tests
on the journal's website if you want to
like
take it for yourself or like use it for
your organization so that's
uh we've talked about on the podcast
before
how it seems to be an inherent conflict
of interest to publish
stuff about like uh uh about uh ayurveda
and like journal of ayurvedic medicine
like
i don't know seems like you kind of have
a vested interest in this stuff working
i don't know seems weird this is far
more direct
it's like if if the journal of ayurvedic
medicine also sold like ashwagandha on
its website like that's
that's some fly by night [ __ ] um
so i i've seen uh myers-briggs described
as astrology for people with linkedin
profiles
and honestly i think that's a little bit
too generous
because like i think a lot of people who
are into astrology
like don't actually believe it they're
just like in it for the vibes you know
like it's
it's it's kind of like uh like people
who are into like
quote of the day type books like if
you've ever
read astrology profiles it's generally
either just like
some piece of generally inoffensive good
advice
or something that's just like oh you're
a great person and everyone should know
that it's kind of like daily
affirmations
uh people who are like really into
myers-briggs
think it's like very scientific and seem
to base like a lot of their personality
around it so
if i had a nickel for every time i've
seen someone like
make a statement that's like as an istj
like i find this very relatable blah
blah blah like that's
uh yeah that's that's some wild [ __ ]
anyway um yeah i'm just looking at the
website now you can get
certified yeah yeah you you can get
certified to be a myers-briggs
practitioner
from this journal website that is
laundering my
myers-briggs ideas it's uh
like that that in and of itself should
uh invalidate it in the minds of a lot
of people if that's
if that's where you got to be publishing
stuff to to show that your
your [ __ ] actually works but anyway um
yeah i just uh i i wanted to talk about
the the
do fasting ad both because the use of
myers-briggs to determine
what type of fasting you should do and
the mere existence of
36-0 intermittent fasting i'm sure that
there's some sort of explanation for
that like maybe it's like snake diet
type [ __ ] where it's like
fast for 36 hours eat one big meal but
there's no explanation of that on the ad
so i
i just wanted to dunk on that a little
bit uh and just to talk about how
dumb the myers-briggs is again to
reiterate it's not that it has no
utility whatsoever but i fail to see any
utility
that it has that the big five doesn't
have
uh big five is more supported uh
contains an extra dimension and that's
the
the neuroticism dimension so like if
you're someone who who's into
myers-briggs
uh just take the big five instead uh
can i blow a hole in your theory here
though oh god go for it
where can i get big five certified
i have no idea yeah i mean if they don't
have a journal website that also
allows me to get certified i can't
actually put these ideas into practice
that is true yeah they they need to
launch something like the journal of the
big five
yeah uh but yeah so i just wanted to
talk about that
uh as an entp i did find it pretty
absurd that people would use
the myers-briggs to uh recommend
intermittent fasting profiles
good stuff um so i want to do a coach's
corner segment we don't do it very often
but there there's a couple of things
that
i've just been doing lately that seemed
to be going really well
and i figured i'd chat about it
extremely briefly but before i do that
i do want to mention i can't even recall
have we talked about p
ratios a lot on the podcast i think we
talked
oh no we haven't put out a uh nor
well you haven't put out a podcast
episode since the article went live
yeah so i i don't want to have like a
whole big discussion about it because
we've written
literal volumes of literature about this
topic but
a while back i know we've at least
mentioned it the concept on the podcast
but
there's this idea floating around that
if you let your body fat get high
it impairs your p ratio it makes it
harder to
make lean gains essentially so for if
your body fat's higher
then it means you know if if you're
trying to bulk up and you gain
three pounds of weight then a smaller
percentage of it is going to be lean
mass
that's the general concept is uh you
know that
having high body fat makes it harder to
make lean gains
or potentially impairs hypertrophy
we don't subscribe to that theory and
wrote a big article about it and then
there was rebuttals and rebuttals to
rebuttals
and so i i guess just to make the
listeners aware if you're interested in
that uh particular content there's a
great deal of written
written work about it that we put
together the last like
two articles on the site i think but uh
on top of that we recently sat down for
a bit of a debate it was
you and me and mike israel and meadow
henselman's and it was hosted by jeff
nippard
and so if you want kind of an audio run
down
of that topic and the back and forth and
the different perspectives
we will link that in the show notes that
our listeners can also give that a
listen
as well now moving on to the coach's
corner
i wanted to very briefly bring some of
these exercises up because i don't know
if everybody else is like me
and hopefully they're not but for me
exercise variations are very cyclical
it's like fashion you know like
something
becomes fashionable and then it goes
away and then like 40 years later people
are like
oh we should bring that back i feel like
i'm always cycling through variations
and i'll just like forget one exists and
then i'll rediscover it later in my
training career and be like
damn that is a sick variation i should
have been doing that the whole time
and so uh it goes from my own training
but also the stuff i do with clients you
know sometimes i'll
i'll get on a streak where i'm like ooh
a lot of people are are really liking
this variation it becomes kind of a
bigger
a bigger part of my programming but a
few things that i've kind of
rediscovered lately first of all it's
completely because of you but
pin squats are awesome you've been doing
them a lot in your own training you had
a mass article about them
so i really couldn't ignore the pin
squat any longer
and i've had a few clients who we've
been working on
you know the hips rising up really
quickly relative to the shoulders
you know trying to make sure that we're
really cueing really explosive movement
out of the hole
keeping the shoulders coming up quickly
keeping the chest up and out
and the pin squats have been great for
that so i've had a lot of clients who
have needed a little bit of work of
explosiveness out of the hole
but also just kind of cueing different
uh technique things out of the hole
and the pin squat has been great for
that another thing that's been great uh
i've got clients who a lot of them are
are training with really
limited resources right now um so
you know instead of being at a
commercial gym due to covid
we've got some dumbbells we got some
random things around the house
and uh one of the
lower body accessory exercises that's
been really sick
for that application is wall squats with
a foam roller
so if you've never done those you're
basically uh leaning up against the wall
squatting but you've got a foam roller
kind of between your lower back and the
wall and what that does is it allows you
to very
comfortably slide up and down as you're
squatting
and from my perspective
it feels a lot like a very suitable
replacement for the hack squat machine
at a gym a really really good
quad stimulus from that my clients have
been loving it and if you're
if you're thinking like how can i get
some quad focus lower body
lower body accessories without a leg
extension machine and a hack squat and a
leg press when you're at home
i think that's a great one uh another
thing that's been helping my clients
with their squats is just really
revisiting the way they grip the bar
i've had a few clients who you know
you know how it is when you're squatting
a lot you'll get the elbow that's
bothering you you get the wrist you get
the shoulder
some of that upper body positioning of
just resting the bar
it can get a little bit tedious cause
some pain and irritation
but just kind of reminding people of
really
first of all switching to a false grip
and getting your thumb on the other side
of the bar
rather than wrapping it around the bar
putting on the same side of the bar as
your other four fingers
and then really giving yourself the
latitude to wedge that bar
down a little lower in your palm just
those little cues
has really made a big difference for
some of my clients lately and
i think sometimes people forget to uh
to remember that you have a lot of
options with how you're actually holding
the bar in a squat
like everybody thinks oh should i go
high bar low bar
neutral but i mean there's a lot more to
placing a bar on your back than just
high low middle you know there's a lot
more to it and
messing around with squat grip has been
really helpful lately
and then finally something that's been
helping a lot of my clients with their
bench is the spoto press and
that's that's such a common accessory i
don't think it falls off the radar for
many people
but if you've never given the spoto
press a try as a bench press accessory
or variation
it is absolutely sick uh really really
really great exercise so
that's all i got those are things that
every now and then i forget about them
and then i remember i'm like
everyone needs to know about these and
be reminded of them
sounds good i i had a coach's corner
planned out too but i was going to talk
about
sticking points and also talk about pen
squats a fair
a fair bit uh so i i think we can i
think we can talk about that on a future
episode
all right sounds good uh now before we
close things out here i do want to get
through some q a questions um
do you want to maybe run through a few
of the q a questions for you and then
i'll do mine
uh yeah sure let's do it so i have uh
i i have four i believe three or four
um so i i solicited these from the
facebook group
and the subreddit uh if you're not
already a member those two places you
can go to
stronger by science community on
facebook or
reddit.com slash r stronger by science
to join
the reddit community um yeah
that's where i got these questions from
and i'll start with uh
some of the highly liked ones from
facebook
so i'm gonna start with peter hergoth um
the question is mouth guards and
performance question mark that is the
full question so i
am assuming uh that's asking about what
are the effects of
uh wearing versus not wearing a mouth
guard versus
versus maybe different types of mouth
guards on
strength performance because i assume
that's what most people are interested
in
so i was able to find five studies that
were potentially relevant to lifters
there's more total studies out there
looking at uh various
athletic things with or without mouth
guards but a lot of them use
aerobic or you know like wind gate test
type outcomes
so so i found five that looked at
strength
and or force and or power outcomes um
and and they'll all be linked in the
show notes and i also came across
a a pretty recent i think 2018
systematic review on just like all
measures of physical performance
including uh aerobic and anaerobic
endurance
those types of things that will also be
linked in the show notes
but in terms of uh power output force
output
of the five studies i was able to find
it's not worth
digging into all of them individually
but basically
we're looking at a fairly evenly split
mix
of slight positive results in favor
of uh of using a mouth guard um
and about half null findings really
really no effect um the the idea behind
wearing a mouth guard
is that if you're able to clinch your
jaw
when you're trying to exert maximal
force or maximal power
um the the like just
clinching uh feeling
clinching motion will help you be able
to increase
force output in some other part of the
body
uh that's not a completely
a completely wild concept so for example
uh
like tensing your core before you do
most lifts will be able to help you
increase
force output a little bit even if you
know you're not necessarily doing like a
core
exercise so uh that is a phenomenon that
exists
and basically when it when it comes to
mouth guards like you can
clinch your jaw a little bit harder and
do so with
a little bit more comfort um
and so yeah it seems like there's a
fairly even mix of
maybe some slight positive effects
versus some measure showing no effect
um and so overall before i would
recommend the use of a mouth guard for
lifting generally i would want to see
more evidence and i'd want to see a more
clear and consistent positive trend in
the research because there
are a lot of null findings in here
um but i i would say that if you're
someone who does
habitually clench your jaw or grind your
teeth when you're training
getting the mouth guard is probably a
pretty good idea
there's no evidence i could find that
it's going to hinder strength or power
performance
and it may help a little bit don't
expect a
particularly large benefit and like i
said and if you don't already clench
your jaw or
grind your teeth when you're when you
train uh i i
don't think it's something that has
enough support to recommend it for
everyone all the time but uh yeah if you
do
already clinch your jaw quite a bit uh
probably
probably not a bad idea to get one uh
do you want me to just run through all
of mine or do you want to yeah yeah
you go ahead okay cool so another one
from facebook from jordan jeffers
uh jordan asks what are the connections
between flexibility and hypertrophy or
strength training
for example does it help to be more
flexible in the target muscle does it
have no impact does it vary by muscle or
exercise
so um there are a lot of
rabbit holes we could go down with this
question but i'm gonna keep it pretty
high level
so um to start with
if you're interested in flexibility
generally you're going to
become more flexible by doing some
stretching so i'm going to talk a little
bit about
the potential effects of stretching
itself first
as i think most people are aware of by
this point doing
a fair amount of pretty intense
stretching
immediately before resistance training
uh probably will have a negative acute
effect on performance and if it's
intense enough
it might even hinder hypertrophy
outcomes however
there was a systematic review published
a couple years ago
suggesting that static chronic static
stretching
performed you know not in the same
session as resistance training
might actually improve muscular
performance a little bit
um and there was also a study from like
a year or two ago
uh looking at the effects of just
resistance training or resistance
training with
with low intensity like pretty light
static stretching for agonist muscles
between sets
finding that that actually increased
hypertrophy a little bit
so you know if you're interested in
flexibility
uh you you're probably going to be
interested in stretching a little bit
and basically as long as you're not
doing just a
ton of super intense static stretching
immediately before your working sets uh
stretching seems like
it's probably going to have a a neutral
to
maybe slight positive longitudinal
effect
on strength and or hypertrophy it's
interesting we were talking about this
earlier
off the air but someone needs to help
stretching kind of rehab its image uh
like we we recently had a mass issue go
up and
there there was one that indicated that
stretching was like you know a little
bit positive
when it comes to uh the goals of a
lifter and people thought it was an
april fool's joke
uh because we we released it on the
first of the month of the month which uh
you know april 1st is
internationally is april fools
recognized
no idea it shouldn't be recognized
anywhere i'm not a big april fool's guy
myself
i think the first of every month should
be a fool's day uh i want june fool's
day i won't august fool's day
i've never come across an april fool's
joke that wasn't funny
i don't want to rain on anyone's parade
here but i find the whole thing to be a
nuisance
i'm a serious boy yeah that's because
you're 156 years old emotionally
but yeah i mean uh it's funny like you
you look at the literature on stretching
and you
you could say oh maybe what we were told
when we were kids really oversold the
benefits but
you know it's it's neutral to slightly
positive so
uh someone needs to uh help stretching
reap it rebrand and uh get get a more
positive uh
more positive vibe out there for
stretching i
agree wholeheartedly uh but anyway so
stretching is not inherently the same
thing as flexibility
you'll you'll probably be stretching to
get more flexible but
you know different people have different
inherent
levels of flexibility independent of
stretching so let's talk about
flexibility itself as an independent
variable
i wasn't able to at least easily come
across any direct research
looking at whether more flexible people
are more or less likely to gain
larger or smaller amounts of strength
and or muscle in response to training
uh but i i think
these these are are rationalist
arguments and they're
they're weak but uh these are my
just kind of thoughts uh on the topic
for hypertrophy i could see
being being really flexible being maybe
a slight drawback um
the reason for that uh is that i think
that
uh muscular tension specifically at long
muscle lengths is pretty important for
muscle growth
uh and a lot of that's just based on
research looking at hypertrophy with
like full range of motion training
versus partial range of motion training
even if you equate for
effort the full range of motion seems to
uh increase hypertrophic outcomes
uh which which is why i think that it's
not just tension that matters but
tension at long muscle links uh being
something that's pretty important
and so basically if you were to get
flexible enough
that most kind of like normal resistance
training
movements wouldn't take you too
particularly long muscle lengths for
yourself
i i could see that possibly being a
slight
drawback for hypertrophy um i don't know
that that would be
uh like the end of the world so for
example um
there's the the research
that i've seen looking at partial versus
full range of motion
training there have been some studies
that uh
like full range of motion say for
squats is defined as like a 90 degree
knee angle which we would often think of
as like half squats and and that seems
to
uh do enough to at least cause like a
pretty robust hypertrophy
response in the quads and so like i i
don't necessarily think that
the important thing is tension at
maximal range of motion i think
as long as range of motion is like
pretty long for the given muscle it's
it's probably sufficient so i don't know
the degree to which that
would matter and also you know there's
you might be dealing with a difference
there between um
like compound versus like isolation type
exercises
so for example um
if you're interested in growing your
hamstrings
and you're doing deadlifts where you
know you're going to have
some non-trivial amount of knee flexion
going on which is going to shorten the
hamstrings
maybe if you just have great hamstring
flexibility and and hamstring length is
really long
you know maybe deadlifts won't train
your hamstrings at quite a long enough
muscle length to maximize the
hypertrophic response
but if you're interested in hypertrophy
you could instead just do
rdls which is just pure hip hinge
very very slight knee bend and you can
make the range of motion as long as you
want to take your
your hamstrings to near end range of
motion so you know
i think most of those concerns
if they're even valid uh could probably
be remedied just by differences in
exercise selection but you know i i
could
i could see being super super flexible
being a slight
negative thing for hypertrophy
and for strength i could also see it
being i could see being really really
flexible being
a slight negative not necessarily for
your ability to build strength
but just around the margins when it
comes to really really top end strength
performance
so when you
do something like when when you uh squat
to full depth or when you
uh bench and bring the barbell down to
your chest
a series of things takes place that is
collectively referred to as
stretch shortening cycle there are a lot
of
individual mechanisms that contribute to
the stretch shortening cycle so
you can get increases in muscle
activation from
the eccentric preload you can get
what's called an increase in muscle
active state which
basically during the the ammo
amortization phase like
when you're transitioning between the
eccentric and concentric
you're kind of like pre-developing actin
and myosin cross bridges that are
already there
when the muscles start shortening during
the concentric and in the more of those
cross bridges you can develop
the larger spike in initial force you
can get when the concentric starts
uh and obviously there are elastic
components to the tendons as well that's
that's probably the first thing that
comes to mind
for people when they think of the
stretch shortening cycle um
so anyway all of those things contribute
and
to some degree at least some of them and
i'm particularly thinking of the
uh elastic contributions here are
probably enhanced a bit
uh by going to by getting a little bit
closer to
end range of motion uh during your
eccentric
and again same type of thing as i was
discussing before if a
like quote unquote full range of motion
for a compound lift
isn't actually taking you all that close
to end range of motion
for the actual target muscles like the
prime movers
uh you you might potentially
be dealing with a slightly smaller
contribution from the stretch shortening
cycle to help you get your
your concentric moving and also just
like
when you get near end range of motion uh
like
passive contractile components uh like
from the connective tissue matrix
running through the muscle
uh contributes more and more contractile
force
as you get closer to end range of motion
so
you know i could see if you're super
super flexible
you might have a little bit less pop
out out of the bottom of a lift and
maybe
a little bit less contribution from the
stretch shortening cycle
i don't know that that's the case but i
i could see it playing out like that
ultimately though i don't think that's a
huge huge deal
um you know so you know if
if you have a really really powerful uh
stretch shortening cycle
and let's say you can uh produce
600 pounds of force isometrically at the
bottom of a squat
via the the magic and mystery of the
stretch shortening cycle
you might you might be able to actually
squat uh
say 6 30 maybe from from that little
boost
that the stretch shortening cycle and
and the passive contractile
contributions give you
to help you get the lift started and
maybe if you have a more shitty stretch
shortening cycle that doesn't contribute
quite as much
maybe instead of squatting 630 you squat
615
so we're not talking about a night and
day difference and i i don't see
why any of that would impact your
ability to
gain strength so in any way i
i could you could sell me on that line
of reasoning
to convince me that being really really
flexible
could could potentially have
slight negative effects on strength
performance
but again i i don't think that it would
be a particularly
notable problem yeah
so i i have quite a few questions i've
just kind of been
saving up the first question i've got
here
i believe is from al and it's actually
two questions first is atp
as a supplement bioavailable and then
is atp supplementation effective for
performance enhancement
atp has extremely poor bioavailability
as far as i'm aware i've seen quite a
few studies looking at that
bioavailability
you seem skeptical greg so i've seen
i've seen an argument that it actually
has
excellent bioavailability but you can't
measure it
uh so the the argument basically goes
that
since atp is such a universal
currency that it moves very very
smoothly between barriers and basically
th
the argument is that as soon as it's
taken up
it it's basically instantly sucked up by
blood cells like red blood cells white
blood cells
uh and so you know generally you'd
measure bioavailability by
you know substance goes in your mouth
and you look at rate of appearance
in in the blood generally in plasma
but if it's immediately being taken up
by red blood cells
you wouldn't necessarily measure it you
wouldn't necessarily be able to measure
it
the same way you would typically measure
oral bioavailability
it's an interesting person i don't i
don't know if that's true
i haven't like fully litigated that but
that is an argument i've seen put forth
in the literature
in a way that kind of transitions nicely
to uh looking at the performance
perspective because i think a very good
question then would be
for something that is so ubiquitous
and so uh easily transferred place to
place and so
constantly uh produced do we
really stand to influence it that much
from dietary supplementation
you know what i mean with how much atp
turnover is constantly happening
and our ability to readily produce it
where it's needed
are you really going to impact your atp
supply via oral supplementation in a
meaningful way
that's going to carry over to some kind
of performance application
for that i'm really really really
skeptical
and there are a few studies looking at
atp
supplementation and effects on
performance
there's one that reports remarkably
positive results um that has received
some letters to the editor of people
saying
can you help me understand why that's
the case
the rest of the studies generally show
negligible impact there are some little
glimmers like little glimpses here and
there of oh did that actually increase
reps to fatigue for this or reps to
fatigue for that
but in the totality it looks
hard to justify the concept that atp as
a supplement is making a big impact on
performance
i maintain a really high degree of
skepticism because i
i just don't think that the mechanisms
that i've seen put across
are particularly
plausible they don't make a lot of sense
to me the
the evidence empirically doesn't seem to
show really reliable
uh performance improvements uh from
study to study
so uh i i'm quite skeptical it would
take a lot more positive evidence for me
to ever recommend
atp as a performance enhancing
supplement the
the mechanistic basis doesn't seem to be
there the reliability of the results
study to study doesn't seem to be there
there are some instances where you can
say hey it did improve one of these
measures in this study but
i'm more inclined to believe that those
findings are spurious more than anything
there was another supplement question
that came up
and it was about phosphatic acid so
pagan strength uh asked the question
what's your take on phosphatidic acid
and phosphatidic acid is interesting um
over the last like five i i guess ten
years or so
it started to be kind of one of those
ingredients that would show up more and
more on the advertisements it was kind
of like the
the flashy new hypertrophy ingredient
and you know it there's always that
ingredient popping up hmb
kind of played that role for a while
they were really adamant
uh marketing a lot of the uh the leucine
metabolites
even aside from hmb uh you know there
was like
i think kik is one in hicka and people
were getting really in into these
different
metabolites but phosphatidic acid was
one of the things that
a lot of people were promoting for
hypertrophy
and uh my buddy adam gonzalez published
a review paper within the last
year or so where you know
he and his colleagues reviewed a lot of
the kind of
newer strength and hypertrophy
supplements on the block and
one of them that they looked at was
phosphatic acid so
the general premise here with
phosphatidic acid is that
theoretically it might facilitate
hypertrophy
by uh by stimulating the the mtor
pathway and then increasing muscle
protein synthesis
and all of a sudden you're building
muscle that's kind of the premise
stimulates mtor stimulates muscle
protein synthesis
and now you've got muscle and you're
pretty stoked about it
as of that review paper there were five
studies that had actually examined
oral supplementation with phosphatidic
acid
in conjunction with resistance training
and usually it was dosed at 250 to 750
milligrams per day
and sometimes it was included alone in
other cases
in a multi-ingredient supplement
only one using phosphatic acid alone of
those five studies reported
significant improvements in strength and
hypertrophy there was another reporting
some positive stuff that use a
multi-ingredient blend so
there were a couple kind of hopeful
optimistic findings early on but it
doesn't seem
that there's a really reliable finding
where phosphatic acid
study after study seems to be uh
inducing you know really favorable
benefits when it comes to strength or
hypertrophy
and there was actually it's kind of
fascinating because there are
some mechanistic studies not many but
there's like one or two studies out
there indicating that
phosphatic acid acute acutely as a
supplement
might actually interfere with
intramuscular anabolic signaling
and that's really fascinating because
there's some of this
mechanistic stuff indicating that it
should facilitate
uh these different anabolic processes
within muscle
but also some isolated findings where it
goes the other direction and blunts
uh some some of those intramuscular
processes that should be
promoting hypertrophy so based on the
kind of
wishy-washy nature of the mechanistic
data
and based on the uh kind of just lack of
strong evidence supporting
its efficacy in these interventions it's
another one of those supplements where
i'm just really not inclined to put out
a lot of enthusiasm or optimism i'm
i'm definitely going to wait on the
sidelines before i get too
hyped up about phosphatidic acid so have
you have you considered
the alternate hypothesis that uh
phosphatidic acid just hasn't worked
that well
in the literature thus far because
people just don't want it bad enough and
maybe
aren't using appropriate parry workout
nutrition to fully benefit from it
i feel like you're reading something
from the internet and i don't know what
uh yeah so i i am on the biotest
sales page for micro pa their
phosphatidic acid supplement
i love biotest uh sales copy so much i
think it's the funniest thing
um so this this is how i became aware of
this particular supplement
but there there's a part on the sales
page will pa
work for you pa being phosphatidic acid
you should honestly answer the following
two questions to determine if you would
benefit from pa use
do you use advanced peri workout
nutrition like
plasma trademarked reactive pump
mag tin registered copyright anabolic
pulse
and surge workout fuel as part of your
training program
all of them you ha you have to
you if you're gonna optimally benefit
from phosphatic acid you need to be
taking at least six other
biotest supplements so how much does a
workout cost
probably like nine or ten bucks uh
okay so that that's the first question
are you using the complete biotest line
of products
uh already if not maybe you don't need
it
uh and then two are you on a
well-designed training program that
includes hard
parentheses intense workout days
question mark biotest recommends that
you always include proper periworkout
nutrition when training
and only take phosphatic acid on hard
workout days
so if you answer no to either question
you're probably not quite
ready for phosphatic acid oh damn you're
it's it's too it's too intense and you
you don't want it bad enough to fully
benefit from it
uh so anyway all i'm saying is we should
teach the controversy and there's
uh there's alternate ideas out there
about
when and for whom phosphatic acid might
be beneficial
we should come out with a dietary
supplement line
but it's by application only so like you
have to apply
to receive the supplement and if you get
approved you have to pay
yeah so are you talking about just run
back the biotest
indigo 3g uh sales promotion
i have no idea what you're talking about
did they beat me to it oh my god yes
this this was this was incredible they
had like a full multimedia event based
on a supplement
launch uh they like hyped it up for
several months
they uh the the first like bottles of it
they sold came in like [ __ ] like
bulletproof kevlar cases uh
to to show how hardcore it was um
and after they'd been hyping it up so
much saying it's it's the best thing
since sliced bread
if you wanted to get your hands on the
first batch of it you had to send in an
application and the way you could get
your hands on it is they'd like
fly you out to the t-nation compound
and uh you you would meticulously take
every t-nation supplement under the sun
along with indigo 3g and uh christian
thibodeaux would walk you through like
five workouts a day
uh while you're you're benefiting from
said indigo 3g and and they uh they did
like a whole like
video production it was like multiple
months they had like
all of the training footage filmed with
like brightly colored water bottles
full of like various biotest liquids
prominently featured in all shots
uh it was it was the most
uh produced supplement rollout i've ever
seen
around what era was this oh man that was
maybe 2012 2013
i can't believe i missed it i i i feel
like i really had my ear to the ground
with
supplements around that time and this
whole biotest thing completely escaped
my
uh uh i think it was 2011.
wow yeah i don't know how i missed all
this man it was
it was intense man it was an insane
supplement roll out and it was
uh they'd been like teasing this thing
that they're like oh man this is gonna
change the game
it was just like some isolated compound
from blueberries
uh that's always the funny part with
supplements that get overhyped is like
you know they talk about it as if it's
like listen
this is some pretty heavy stuff it's
pretty intense uh
you know it they they treat it like it's
this like controlled substance you're
like what is it it's like oh it's
mushroom extract
found some mushrooms this is in it um
all right so this one is a good one it
comes up all the time
uh so nick likes to train
and he also likes soda and so he knows
on a population level
sugary drinks are associated with a
whole bunch of health problems
and the question was like
mechanistically what's going on here and
if i'm someone who's healthy and i'm
working out and training and maintaining
a healthy body weight but i just like
soda is the soda actually going to be
bad for me
yeah and that's a really good question
and over the last couple years i think
we've gotten a lot more clarity when it
comes to
not just giving a practical answer but
actually digging in and doing some
studies to figure out mechanistically
what's going on there
and you know from looking at the
literature and i'll post a couple links
in the show notes
it looks like the the biggest issue here
when it comes to fructose is
or sugary drinks i should say is first
of all they tend to be pretty high in
fructose
and fructose coupled with inactivity
puts the liver in a pretty tight spot
and that ultimately is what contributes
mechanistically
to a lot of the negative things we
associate with
uh sugary beverages of course aside from
just being in a
calorie surplus that's kind of the easy
thing so
uh of course if you have a ton of sugar
in your diet that's just kind of
adding and adding and adding to an
excessive calorie surplus
then that's going to have its own
independent impact but
what's really fascinating is that
fructose specifically gets metabolized a
little bit differently
than glucose and that has ramifications
for the liver and you know glycemic
control and blood lipid responses after
that consumption and so a few recent
studies have looked at well
what happens if you're taking in these
huge amounts of fructose
but you're not in a calorie surplus or
you're super active so you're actually
clearing a lot of
uh fuel sources out of the liver on a
day-to-day basis because you're using
carbohydrate with physical activity
and you're not just accumulating a bunch
of excess energy in the form of sugar
and what those studies have largely
found is that
extra sugar particularly coming from
fructose
doesn't seem to be a huge deal as long
as you're relatively weight stable and
relatively active
so for example in one study they had 10
healthy people
taking in 150 grams a day of fructose
which is a ton so like table sugar is 50
fructose yeah 50 fructose so to get 150
grams of fructose from table sugar we're
talking 300 grams of sugar
uh high fructose corn syrup i think a
lot of people
are under the misconception that most of
the high fructose corn syrup out there
is like 90
fructose that's really not the case most
of it's about 55
fructose 45 uh glucose
so the practical differences uh
between 55 fructose corn syrup and table
sugar
very very minimal but but yeah so if
we're talking 150 grams of fructose
that's a hell of a lot of sugar in your
diet
and they were they were fed this 150
extra grams of fructose per day for
eight weeks
and you know they looked at a whole host
of potential issues related to
uh you know the liver looking at all
sorts of
metabolic consequences that may result
from excess fructose intake
and everything was fine so so for these
young folks who were weight stable
that's the key
during that study they really didn't
have any
negative ramifications from that huge
intake of fructose
and there was also a study looking at
physical activity so
for 14 days people were given
uh 75 extra grams of fructose a little
bit more
you know possible intake without going
really far out of your way to get a
bunch of sugar in the diet like 75 grams
of fructose a day
is still a high dose but i mean you know
150 grams of fructose is a ton
but anyway 75 extra grams for 14 days
and they did this on two different
occasions
on one occasion they had low physical
activity so 4 500 steps per day
which uh i mean i'm in isolation
quarantine mode and that's yeah that
that's
hitting close to home right there with
that step count but
they also did the same intervention in a
different uh
condition where they had high physical
activity and it was twelve thousand
five hundred steps per day uh so so
those are the two conditions they're
a pretty big discrepancy in physical
activity level
and that extra 75 grams of fructose
yeah you know it had some negative
impacts uh
when they were in the low physical
activity uh condition
but it was completely blunted completely
alleviated when they were in the higher
physical activity condition
um so i i think the picture when it
comes down to sugar and fructose
it really has to be contextualized and
the question is
if your weight stable and you have a
pretty high activity level
is it something that really ought to be
worried about and in my in my opinion
based on the data it's probably not a
big deal
i think the biggest uh the biggest
consideration is making sure that your
total energy intake is suitable for your
activity level
um and that you're generally being
active not just for managing
uh the fructose load that you're
bringing in but just
to generally be good to your body you
know high physical activity level
within reason you know without going way
on the higher ends of
you know just constantly moving around
the entirety of your day
we generally want to have some degree of
physical activity in our day to day
schedule so
personally i really wouldn't worry about
it if you're weight stable at a healthy
body weight and you're physically active
i i don't think there's any
huge reason to be overly restrictive
when it comes to
sugar sweetened beverages however big
caveat first of all
i'm no dentist but i've heard it can be
kind of bad for your teeth to drink a
lot of soda
so you know maybe that's important to
you but like i said i don't know
anything about it not a dentist
but another thing is you want to make
sure that you're not displacing
important nutrients from your diet so
you might say well i'm weight stable i'm
on a low calorie intake but i'm drinking
a bunch of soda
well if your calories are low and you're
drinking a bunch of soda
you might be struggling to get in you
know plenty of fiber
vitamins minerals and otherwise good
stuff
that would typically come with a lot of
other carbohydrate sources so
as long as you're not displacing
important stuff from your diet
and as long as you're maintaining
maintaining a healthy body weight
not in a huge surplus and you're
physically active i i think you're
probably pretty okay
makes sense to me all right so
willowbarker17 asks
or starts by stating would love to hear
your thoughts on neck strength and its
relationship
to likelihood of receiving a concussion
i always see
the quote collins at all 2014
close quote study preached by contact
sport coaches
saying for every pound of neck strength
odds of concussion
is reduced by five percent i'm just too
stupid to figure out if this is true and
if so to what extent
um so yeah uh asking about neck strength
and
uh risk of concussion so once again i i
previously gave a a
disclaimer that i'm not a doctor so
don't take what i have to say
about fat free mass index and mortality
risk is medical advice i am also not
i don't know a physical therapist brain
trauma person
uh neuroscientist yeah what yeah i'm not
i'm not a
i'm not a not much of anything no now
that i think about it i'm really not
yeah i have no no formal expertise
whatsoever
uh so don't don't take anything i say uh
too seriously at all
but um but yeah so
uh let's let's talk about uh this topic
whether
having a bigger stronger neck will
actually
reduce your risk of concussions you are
a concussion aficionado i think
yeah so uh you know there's a difference
between
book learning and experiential learning
and
maybe i don't have that that much of
that their book learning when it comes
to concussions but i have
i'm probably in the top like one
percentile globally when it comes to
hands-on experience with concussions
in the trenches experience yeah
uh both both with giving and receiving
them
uh don't lead with your head kids
anyway um so yeah uh
the the question referenced a study by
collins and colleagues from 2014 uh and
and that is basically a direct quote
from the study for every pound of neck
strength uh concussion risk decreases by
five percent that was
the headline finding of that study um
but instead of just focusing on that i
think it's worth noting that there are
more studies that have been conducted
that have looked at
the association between neck strength or
even the effects of neck
training on concussion risk or
various like head acceleration related
variables
during contact that might predispose
someone to to uh brain trauma
um so yeah uh there there was a 2018
uh review by honda and colleagues that's
going to be
linked in the show notes uh that that
looks at several things so it looks at
the impact of neck strength and neck
training
on concussion risk but it also looks at
vision training and reaction time and
reaction time type training on
concussion risk as well
those are some other things that that
can uh you know
go into the whole picture of concussion
risk but it has a
a nice section on the impact of
neck strength and neck training on
concussion risk and here is
a choice quote directly from that review
so
um quote according to the literature
there are inconclusive results for neck
strength preventing concussions
in basketball lacrosse rugby and soccer
increased neck strength seems to lead to
fewer concussions but in hockey and
football
neck strength does not seem to affect
concussions
researchers concluded anticipating a
head impact
and allowing the cervical neck
musculature to brace for the impact
reveals less head movement and
acceleration following the head impact
which may lead to less concussions so
here i think is
is the basic takeaway uh in sports
where collisions and
head impacts are just [ __ ] huge so
american football and hockey
it may not really matter all that much
how strong your neck is
because the head trauma is just so
great that necks don't get that strong
and
you know having a big strong neck
probably isn't going to hurt you but
you're just hitting heads too hard at
too
high of speeds with too large of people
uh
that maybe it just doesn't make that big
of a difference
uh you know this goes back to something
this is one of my little like bugaboos
um
helmets make football so much more
dangerous uh
they really do because you can use them
as a weapon
and i understand uh why they're there
like from a fan perspective like
you know if someone say like takes a
a slash to the face or something or side
of the head like
it looks bad as a fan to see blood
coming out of someone's head or
or all over someone's face like that
looks like it should be pretty serious
and they bleed a lot a laceration oh
yeah the face or the scalp
yeah highly vascularized yeah bleeds a
ton uh so it looks really bad but like
ultimately like scratches heal up uh
brain trauma long term doesn't seem to
actually
fully heal up that well uh so yeah
you give someone a helmet uh they're
going to take on more head impacts than
they would if they didn't have a helmet
but anyway
um yeah yeah football and hockey
it probably doesn't hurt to have a
strong neck but it could just be that
the human neck cannot become
strong enough to to deal with the
demands of those sports
uh i find that very plausible however uh
it did seem like
having a stronger neck in sports that
don't have
as absurd of head trauma so basketball
lacrosse
rugby and football everywhere else in
the world what we would call soccer
it does seem like having a stronger neck
does reduce concussion risk in those
sports where
head trauma is not as severe so i i do
think this paints the overall picture
that neck training is good for reducing
concussion risk
even though it it may not actually end
up reducing risk
in uh football and hockey is
again it's it's still probably not a
terrible idea to do some neck training
and for other sports
it will probably be beneficial
but it's also worth noting that simply
having a stronger neck
probably doesn't fully address the issue
one of the other things they talk about
in this review
is that if you are more aware that a
large impact is coming
and you can uh you know see that in time
to be able to brace your neck well
that's going to basically make your head
whip less less
accelerated forces and that can lessen
the
total head trauma that you experience um
and so in addition to strengthening your
neck uh
it's probably not a bad idea to just
work on improving
general awareness of of the plane space
you're working with the quarter the
field
uh and doing some maybe reaction time
training
so that you know if if you see that
person coming out of the corner of your
eye you can
you can brace your head or brace your
neck well enough uh before
impact actually comes to to be able to
protect yourself a little bit
uh so yeah neck training probably a good
thing
if head impacts are intense enough
maybe it's not going to make that big of
a difference um
but also like improving your general
awareness and reaction times
should work synergistically with having
a stronger neck to
reduce your concussion risk okay and the
last question i'm going to address is by
bikini
underscore car wash who says i'd love to
hear about modifying programming based
on caloric intake
specifically whether volume intensity or
frequency should be titrated based on
whether one
is cutting or bulking also if doing
alternating strength blocks and
hypertrophy blocks
whether one should coincide with cutting
and the other with bulking or vice versa
bro science dogma is quote don't change
your program
but i'm not sure if there is any good
evidence out there to support that
that last sentence there is pretty
prescient there is not good
evidence out there to support this
either way
this is one of the common arguments that
you'll see in the
evidence-based health and fitness space
if you're in a calorie deficit should
you try to
maintain volume while maybe sacrificing
intensity a little bit should you try to
maintain
intensity while maybe sacrificing volume
a little bit
one of the reasons why that can be such
a robust
argument and topic for discussion is
that there's really no good direct
evidence on the topic
i'm not aware of any study where they
say like okay we're gonna put
two groups of people in a controlled
calorie deficit one of them
uh you know we're gonna start them on
the same training program
and as performance decreases as this
diet progresses
one of the groups we're going to
maintain volume while sacrificing
intensity and the other group are going
to maintain intensity while sacrificing
volume
that would be an ideal study i haven't
seen that or
really anything even comparable to it be
done in the literature so
this is an open question um
my personal perspective on it is that
um a lot of it's just gonna come down to
how large the deficit or surplus is
uh well we're gonna mostly talk about
deficit i mean
surplus like things that work at
maintenance should just work better in a
surplus
uh so when you're talking about a
deficit i think the two things that
matter is
uh how large is that deficit and how
lean are you already
if you have a fair amount of fat to lose
and it's a pretty modest deficit
i don't think you really need to make
any proactive changes to your training
approach because
at least for like a pretty solid while a
small deficit with a fair amount of fat
to lose shouldn't really
impact your training all that much in
the first place
certainly not enough to make large
proactive changes
it may be worth modifying your training
if
you either are already lean and you're
trying to get
considerably leaner or if you are
intentionally taking a more extreme
approach to dieting like let's say
you're going on a protein sparing
modified fast or something like that
you've you've presently been doing
pretty high volume training
you kind of size it up and say i don't
think i'll be able to
survive this level of training with 800
calories per day and no carbs uh
in a situation like that i think your
best bet
honestly is to just kind of like lean in
the direction
of the training that uh
causes the smallest fatigue burden for
you so for some people
uh reasonably high volumes really trash
them but like high intensity stuff
yeah generally pretty fine and on the
flip side some people
you know you get much above 85 percent
of your max you start grinding triples
uh now you're having issues recovering
you feel like [ __ ] all the time but like
higher volumes
go down pretty smooth like i think just
how people
respond to different training variables
differs quite a bit
and i think that if you're in a
situation where recovery is going to be
limited
either due to the fact that you're
already pretty lean
or that your deficit is pretty large
i think you should just kind of lean
towards the variable
that causes the smallest fatigue burden
for you so for me personally
uh volume [ __ ] me up so like i'm gonna
cut volume but try to maintain
intensity pretty well other people you
know
the the intensity may [ __ ] them up more
so they'd try to maintain volume more i
think that that's
i think that's largely a personal
preference decision
um and
ultimately i think for the most part
unless you're taking a pretty extreme
approach
your best bet is to be reactive rather
than proactive
basically because you're not going to be
able to perfectly predict
the degree to which say a small to
modest calorie deficit
will impact your ability to train and
recover
once you start training you will figure
that out it may not have an impact at
all it may have
a modest impact may have a fairly large
impact so i think your best bet is to
basically roll into it with the style of
programming that has previously been
working for you pretty well
uh and then no
anticipate that you're probably going to
need to make changes
eventually and basically just scale the
magnitude of those changes with
the the magnitude of the difficulties
you're running into like if
you get four months into a diet and now
you're having issues recovering but it's
not huge issues like
you know maybe you can bump intensity
down five percent or dial volume back
by like one set per exercise per week
and you'll be pretty good
uh if you you know even go into a pretty
modest deficit but two weeks in
you feel absolutely crushed okay now
that's
information suggesting that maybe you
should make larger reactive changes to
your training program but i think that
largely unless you're doing something
pretty extreme again like a protein
protein-sparing modified fast or
something similar
uh it it pays to be reactive rather than
proactive because
you're not going to be able to perfectly
forecast
uh how much a deficit is going to affect
you
yeah i think another thing to keep in
mind is
something that we often forget which is
there is good evidence that we can
maintain some pretty nice
training adaptations while dropping
volume
so this often comes up
like obviously my background is in
bodybuilding
and so you know you're going to be doing
some pretty extreme stuff at the end
you're going to be getting as lean as a
person would want to get your calories
are going to be very
low your performance is going to be hit
by that you're not going to go and say
actually my high rep performance and my
top end strength are both doing fine
like you're not going to find that a lot
and so for me when i when i manipulate
my training
in that context i often think first of
all
it's not just what is harder to recover
from but what can i actually complete
in the gym what what aspect of my
performance
can i actually maintain as i
get toward the end of this pretty nasty
process
and so for me my higher rep
my higher volume work seems to really
suffer i often have to cut my rep ranges
down
and i often have to drop my number of
sets because there's just
from an energetic a bioenergetic
perspective there's nothing left
maybe i should be using atp supplements
or something like that but
i've got nothing left and and so i often
have to air toward
higher intensity lower volume approaches
than my off-season
but i i do find it reassuring that we
there's some pretty solid evidence out
there that you can drop
volume pretty pretty substantially
and maintain what you've got so that's
kind of a short-term solution that's
more
maintenance focused than progress
focused but if you find yourself in a
pretty similar scenario or you're toward
the tail end of a pretty hard
cut that that is a body of literature
that provides some reassurance
now big caveat is that that literature
doesn't involve a calorie deficit
uh so we are kind of taking literature
from
what i assume to be pretty uh
energetically neutral conditions
probably around
energy balance and applying that to a
caloric deficit in this case but
i i do still expect that the general
principle should hold up pretty well
uh even when transitioning it from one
context to the other
so so that's uh my my perspective on the
topic just from the
exact place i find myself in when
weighing that is
you know usually it's just a matter of
what can i actually accomplish in the
gym effectively
and what am i sacrificing when i cut
that volume i know
i've talked to helms about this as well
and i know he and i have a similar
approach and we start really pushing
those
those uh fat loss efforts we
we often tend to drop some of the fluff
some of the extra volume the accessory
work just to make the workouts a little
bit more manageable
okay i think that does it uh for this
episode we should be
uh should be ready to play us out here
so what do you have for us this week
do you have anything i don't i have
absolutely nothing that's very
interesting
since this is your podcast but uh that's
fine i i can i can pick up the torch and
carry us over the finish line
so i've got a couple food related things
as has kind of become the general theme
of the to play us out segment
the first is a recipe recommendation so
um i came across a recipe for
olive oil blondies by sola l whaley
on youtube from food uh
we can link that video in the show notes
they are exceptional they are so good um
what's a blondie there's some in the
fridge right now you can have one when
we're done recording
it's uh it's kind of the same vibe as a
brownie so it's
uh it's like dense and chewy instead of
cakey
but it's it's not made with chocolate um
but anyway so instead of using butter
as the as the primary fat in the recipe
it uses
olive oil and uh i don't think i'd ever
ha no that's a lie i was gonna say i
didn't think i'd ever had an olive oil
based dessert before
i i have had an olive oil cake which was
which was good but didn't really blow me
away but these
these olive oil blondies blow me away
they're so
good uh something about
the the the alchemy that takes place
between the olive oil and the brown
sugar
really brings out the floral notes of
the olive oil
um and it's it's a very interesting
flavor
and it works it works so well
and it's one of the first like truly new
tastes that i've had on my palette when
it comes to desserts in a long long time
uh i'm not someone who's particularly
big on sweets
i i got very fat from eating a lot of
cheeseburgers not necessarily like
pastries and whatnot that's that's not
generally how i roll
this is the first uh sweet confection
i've had in a while
where just like the hedonic drive kicks
in and i want to eat like the whole pan
they're they're very very good um
so yeah we can link that in the show
notes something about that just
olive oil is weird i i like olive oil
but i wish it's flavor were turned down
about 40 percent
you know like sometimes the olive oil
whenever i'm
cooking with it it just hits a little
too strong and it's
it's a little much for me i don't know
how i would
handle that in a dessert well that's how
i mean it's cut with
uh a fair bit of brown sugar and a lot
of flour
both of which like mute the really
strong olive oil flavors
well i'll give it a try i'm open-minded
but i'm very nervous
hearing olive oil as a sweet dessert
fair enough uh anyway so it's it's very
good you should at minimum check out the
video they were
very tasty uh the other thing on on a
much
a much healthier food note um i don't
think i've mentioned this on the podcast
before
but uh i've been meal prepping more um
and so you know just basically cooking
in bulk things that are pretty macro
friendly
and i've been saving all of those things
to my saved stories on instagram
and so basically if you're if you're if
you're interested in food prepping
something that has pretty decent macros
uh that might be a little bit more
exciting than chicken and rice if that's
you know if you've been meal prepping
the same basic foods for a long time and
you want something just new to
to keep it fresh in recent weeks we've
made
ziti we've made taco casserole which
uh basically came out as like uh
uh oh what's it called hamburger helper
like it had
strong hamburger helper vibes it was
very good uh
pizza this week uh that looked good that
looked really good
you can have a slice it's it's pretty
solid
uh we made dumpling casserole like it it
tastes very very reminiscent of like a
chinese pork dumpling
uh and last week we made cottage pie
which also came out really really well
so uh recipes for those things and
videos walking you through step by step
of how to make them
uh and the nutrition information for
them you can find all of that stuff
on my save stories on my personal
instagram account
uh if if you want something to uh to
make meal prep
a little more fresh those stories are
are really i mean
some of them i think are very
referential to some of the stuff i make
and referential's being kind and you
know that i
i can promise you that it's not
i think i'm being more than charitable
but okay
um but now that if if you
are not like me and you want to get a
little bit more exploratory and
adventurous with your meal prep
they're really creative creative ways to
make
macro-friendly food for the entire week
which is
which is i think a really valuable thing
to put out there
um speaking of putting valuable things
out there we're back
it's season four so uh that does it for
this episode
but we will be back in a couple weeks as
always
thanks for listening thank you for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description
of today's episode finally please
remember that we are not medical doctors
or registered dietitians so before you
make any changes to your exercise or
nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you